Alastor I mean what do you make of this
whole you know the publicity surrounding
this personal stuff does a sort of lovey
dovey picture in the Sussex countryside
basically put it to rest it makes a lot
of people vomit to be absolutely Frank I
mean that you can't have you I know he
likes to have his cake and eat it you
can't on the one hand say that I'm
entitled to privacy on the other hand
rejoice in having this picture out there
so is that the right-wing papers can say
these wonderful loving loving couple and
look the Tory Party membership has got a
massive responsibility and they have to
decide are they choosing a soap opera
for the next few years or are they
actually choosing a prime minister and
I'm less interested to be frank in his
private life about which there's an
awful lot to know which he doesn't want
to talk about then I am in his failure
to answer questions really serious
questions about brakes it about taxation
about publics about public services
because he's frankly that's what he's
avoiding and look I'd say one thing to
both of them they both been in senior
positions in in politics there is a
massive gap between any job they have
ever done before and being Prime
Minister and it is absolutely
fundamental that not just the
Conservative Party but the whole country
has the right to see them tested to see
their mettle tested and the fact that
he's running away from it so it says to
me that deep down he probably knows he's
not up to it right well that's a point
Craig I mean it may be Craig that the
personal stuff is playing quite well
with him because he allows him to say
look the media are just interested in
tittle-tattle and allows him to sort of
get off the hook over the issues that
that Alastair Campbell's just been
talking about I'm not so sure that's
true I don't think he'd have joined
working up this morning - Jeremy Hunt's
article in The Times saying that he was
running scared and he was essentially a
chicken I think what's really going on
here is that the campaign is looking out
there and say look how much can we get
away with not exposing him too much they
are nervous about having an amount
they're too much and they are trying to
actually basically turn the volume down
a bit because they're so far ahead it is
doing a bit of damage but is it doing it
enough damage and I think the even
bigger question that's going on at the
moment is just as the Labour Party's
members have been radicalized
korban have the Conservative Party
members been regular radicalized over
Boris and there's almost nothing that
you can say that is actually going to
damage him people who know more about
the Conservative Party than me are
saying at the moment that they think he
is still a shoe-in and the Conservative
Party probably needs to go through a
phase of having him there because he
needs to be tested and know in the next
stage of brexit so announced Campbell if
you were representing Boris Johnson
would you be saying you should be doing
these debates I mean Boris Johnson sort
of thrives on contact with the public it
always seemed to me why I know you
trying to protect tony blair and craig
tried to protect David Cameron but would
you be saying go ahead and do these
debates now of course and also listening
to Craig there I mean look this is all
being discussed in the frame of the Tory
Party leadership and whether he's being
clever about his tactics this guy thinks
he should be Prime Minister at one of
the most pivotal pivotal times in our
history it is a fundamental outrage that
he is refusing to engage on some of
these incredibly serious questions and
you saw today
Priti Patel quasi quieting out there is
these proxies pathetically under briefed
they don't have the answers to the
questions on Bracy because he doesn't
have the answers to the question on
breaks it and you guys mark your
profession honestly I think you are
rather than just sort of discussing this
in tactics you should be door stepping
the hell out of the guy you should not
be letting in walk down the street
without answering some of these
questions and we've got to get out of
this idea this is all just about this is
about choosing our next prime minister
yeah but with the greatest respect door
stepping doesn't achieve that much I
sort of sit down interview sit-down
interviews or a one-to-one debate
achieves something and that's what we've
invited him to do so you know we've done
our bit to be but yes you may have done
but honestly you've got to put this guy
under proper sustained scrutiny and
pressure you should not in my view be
allowing these proxies to come on and
talk absolute Tosh about his plans for
brick see that guy's got to be pinned to
a chair as you say and he's going to be
forced to answer these questions I think
people in the country you have to
understand as well about Theresa May
Theresa May wasn't tested in her
leadership relation because there wasn't
one and look what happened when he got
to an election
she fell apart and I think Tories need
to start wondering why is he so scared
of getting out there and getting
properly utilized